welcome to this video playing QQ key
okay let's see here NIM though probably
let's play something else they have
three line currently very much in
fashion also what I recommend that back
then in my video series in Jack late
what that what was that 2011 or
something really old one no um and he's
playing the old main line yeah in Carl's
install this is what Magnus did and was
that the final game no it was pre-final
gamer and they're in there from the
world championships in 2013 quinces 7 or
how do you play here I should be three
it's not good do you go night 92 first I
read along
okay I'm getting that space here it's a
TED weakening but ok g5 is a threat i
think and this Bishop is somewhat
somewhat exposed now like h 4 and so on
might be overly aggressive but ok well I
don't mind that push-ups eat or what is
the point i don't quite get it ok let's
see yeah maybe he wants to go Bishop see
tool
yep okay so Queen d21 and tending maybe
we should be 231
hmm yeah it should be over here there
was g5 still home if I check him on b5
he has to play Knight to d7 maybe a
check or move the king theoretically
speaking but King move looks really
strange
you should be too maybe queen bee six
it's also queen before to prevent his
castling that's not bad I think it's
interesting if he really wants to cast
Lee has to play some rather unwelcoming
moves there on the queenside a-six
a-five stuff like that yeah yeah I
thought I can actually maybe just take
it maybe just take it because he has to
how to see we capture with a king Jack
90s 95 yeah and this this I thought
would we win another tempo here or maybe
a four even if I rook c8 then okay
I don't know maybe maybe that wasn't
that great as a thought I mean Bishop d7
was definitely not necessary move I
could have played just the bishop bag I
probably probably is okay yeah
play is probably okay em we should be
for now I can maybe just plug into the
seven while King f 24 h for some turkey
and but that's probably a move worth
playing because without canceling it
will still be not easy for him cannot t
unfortunately i can actually if i do
this a 5 i can take that pawn for queen
bee aid quincy that trade takes it too
so I'm preventing this ok now we move
the bishop I'll take on c4 pawn takes d5
let's let's do it have to be quick here
I thought that this might be good oil it
could be it is a bit risky without long
calculation to play this but if I get in
I mean I think he has to take and
somehow I now Queen g7 otherwise it's
just too bad I maybe you can play Quincy
seven but it doesn't look right and then
I play d6 and Queenie five check ok so
90 x screen g7 it will do a min material
for me I'm just not sure if you have
some kind of vicious counter-attack
probably not okay yeah I'll just get in
the check on
five so it is really good right yes and
check him King back to d8 queen bee a
check Quincy a that I can take b6 check
if I'm not seeing anything better which
I which I don't but that's that's good
enough check I've made black reasons
okay so let's check this especially b7
was a really debatable decision i
believe probably not good ok went there
and i think this is a pretty good
position for wide a d5 is weak and the
two bishops account for something plus
he hasn't castled a compounds to go g5
here on something radical and now the
engine just wants the paper should be to
wear that sets the the normal move check
this shouldn't be bad right okay it's
bad in comparison with me g5 seems to be
pretty good yeah that makes some sense
that the night has to retreat now and
here it's not not that clear what I have
alright still rather be white here but
it's not not not not clearly this is
what he did yeah now I took I mean okay
I can go back but check that was really
the idea now try to do something with
his castling prevented yeah the engine
always wants to play g5 and the computer
is right they're glued eyes right when
the night has to retreat that and my
active night is the key to my position
here it's again g5 if you never played
that move no no I'm better now after
King d2a back yeah and this was not
working to do to what happened in the
game
in a five I can take because of this
Adam check the engine however just wants
to cancel and play this position which
is kind of curious why cannot i cannot
just take here what is the point Queen a
form and the pollution is equal
according to the end yeah this is
winning for black Wow we'd be three or
something am i king is a bit shaky okay
went here now this dude will ride 25
yard wide wins me and I was thinking
okay if this is ok I have this chat ah
that's much stronger than Queen g7 or at
least it's simpler I mean that probably
wins as well but yeah it does win at
this one as well hey this is so much
much as much easier yes it doesn't have
just made and then I'm just taking this
next move with a with a very very simple
win yeah interesting interesting game
here but he really could have defended
much much better if he was if he would
have found the g5 resource okay well
thanks for watching